ça fait drôle de revenir ou pas georges
ses traces ah oui pareil là c'est mon
enfance là c'est le prix de missiles
c'est le prix de ma patience
dans sa bouche douce oms à saint sever
dans le calvados avec notre invité
arnold turboust on va aller consacrer
entièrement ceux là où ça bouge
il sera un nouvel album qui s'appelle
arnold turboust ou simplement très bon
album on en parle pendant toute
l'émission c'est parti
arnold c'est là que vous êtes né juste
là on part en tenait une boucherie ici
même et vous vous êtes né là auxerre pas
à l'hôpital mais là au moins je sais pas
pourquoi mais changer je suis né au
dessus ça me fait quelque chose c'est
plus la boucherie d'ailleurs c'est plus
rien tous les commerçants ont disparu
souffle
au monde ben c'est à dire ouais petit
son papa était bouché la lumière et les
bouchons
vous avez appris la musique ici à saint
sever la la maison là à côté
mademoiselle charton
alors ensuite vos parents fit saint
sever pour arriver ici à torigni et
c'est toujours la boucherie c'est
toujours la boucherie où vous ne devenez
pas bush et savaient pas le métier dans
le sang au maroc
tombé
ma chambre était celle ci voilà la sexy
la deuxième ouais ouais
alors là vous avez composé tombés pour
la france voilà j'avais proches sur un
petit homme qui santé un farfisa
t'adaptes adam dada mta dame talent
comment s'est faite cette rencontre avec
diane la rencontre importante pour nous
c'est une rencontre très importante
c'est la rencontre avec rennes quelque
part j'étais j'étais au lycée à saint lô
à le verrier oui au lycée le verrier est
un de mes principes mais grands copains
c'était éric morinière qui jouait de la
batterie et nous tous les midis ont joué
dans le gymnase et après le bac que moi
je suis partie au havre et lui il est
parti à rennes est il à illies à jouer
qui joue avec marquis de sade il m'a
appelé parce qu'ils allaient enregistrer
un album avec la ruda leur kit saad
voilà il avait besoin d'un clavier et
donc c'est comme ça que je suis arrivé à
rennais etienne était très pote avec
tous ces musiciens de marquis de sade
c'est comme ça que j'ai rencontré et je
lui ai dit si tu veux je pourrais te
faire des chansons il m'a dit où un beau
jeu m'a dit oui je joue moins
mais ce mot
rendez vous aux jardins
rendez vous dont
justement rendez-vous à arromanches pour
un des lieux de balade préféré d'arnold
le normand qui vit à paris aujourd'hui
alors maintenant charnelle on va parler
de votre album qui s'appelle arnold
turboust un album éponyme on appelle ça
comme ça mais c'était pas d'autres
titres que votre nom ça veut dire que
vous l'assumez plus le résoudre
peut-être ce nouvel album est coréalisé
avec un ami musicien rico koning qu'elle
travaille notamment avec des bêches mode
lui aux états unis arnold en france donc
méthodes modernes de travail on a
échangé des fichiers via internet
on s'est réunis juste pour le mixage
c'est à dire il est venu ici en france
et pendant trois semaines un mois on va
finaliser l'album ensemble
source
j'écris en fait je pense commun comme un
compositeur c'est à dire c'est très
sonore parce que j'ai besoin de choses
sonore
ouais je pense que ça me flatte c'est
moi je ne vais pas chercher du tout à
faire de la musique que pour plaire à
machin ou ma chance j'essaie juste de
faire ce que j'aime ce que j'ai envie ce
que je suis allé à la découverte de ce
nouvel album d' arnold turboust salut
arnold
direction maintenant le café des images
à hérouville avec la présence dimanche
exceptionnel du cinéaste chinois wang
bing
ce sera sa seule date en province il
viendra présenter son nouveau film
et puis musique maintenant pour terminer
avec les autres 56 en concert demain à
la salle du triumph bahebeck revon à la
main